it is a very interesting conversation
that's happening in second what about
what Stedman said well I I do think
that's interesting because Stedman says
that he thought the reporter said to him
would she make a good president and he
said absolutely she would that's what
that's how he interpreted the question
because this is a thing Stedman would
wouldn't never so cavalierly say
absolutely she would do it it's up to
the people he would never do to do that
I got I got nine young people yesterday
but wait no I got emails from before
yesterday that said Stedman being
strategic or is he being supportive he
is nothing but supportive he would never
just throw it out there like that what
were you gonna say well I'm going to ask
you the same tough question that I asked
guests on this show
in fact Stedman did say she would
absolutely do it it's up to the people
everybody said yeah he did say it is up
to the people but I'm telling you his
interpretation of the question was would
she he thought she was
he thought the reporters saying would
she be a good okay is she considering it
no I absolutely don't think that her
position has changed I don't you know I
was up talking to her very late last
night I do think this though guys I do
think she's intrigued by the idea I do
think that I also know that after years
of watching the Oprah show you always
have the right to change your mind I
don't think at this point she is
actually considering it but listen there
are people who were who said they want
to be her campaign manager who want to
quit their jobs and campaign for her she
loves this country and would like to be
of service in some way but I don't think
that she is actively for the record that
is a that is a change from what we heard
in October it's not a change from her
job that's a change for me so let me ask
you who wrote the speech listen
Oprah crafted that speech she knew how
she wanted to start this was the thing
for her she knew exactly what she wanted
to say and she knew how she wanted to
say it she she crafted the speech he
talked to an editor at the magazine and
and the two of them came up with it but
Oprah put down exactly what she wanted
to say those were all her words you know
listen she writes her what I know for
sure column every week every month in
the magazine she's a very good writer we
all know she's a very good talker and so
I think that it
a homerun on many levels I thought being
in that room I will say this being in
that room was electrifying it was the
right person giving the right speech at
the right time she wanted that moment to
be more than women wearing black dresses
of solidarity she really did want to
speak to young girls around the country
she really did want to say enough
already and I think she delivered on all
that in a very eloquent way but will she
run for president I think it's I I I
think it's a very intriguing idea if
something else if someone were to
potentially run for president what do
you think their timeline might be I
don't know Jeff I'm just looking at this
yes you can
no private up out the P would say Nora
wasn't reeving I don't think there is
such a thing as a timeline I'm not
trying to be cute here or be mysterious
but I do think it's a very intriguing
thing that she had never considered
people said oh yeah
she wrote that speech as a launching pad
for what she wants to do that's
absolutely not true she worked on it she
rehearsed it she practiced it I was a
practice audience member and I have to
say I knew that speech was going to be
powerful just when she was reading at
the time and you'll like this before
when she was there at rehearsal they
told her she had to cut three minutes
out of it because it was six minutes
long they said you have to cut it to
three minutes and Oprah said if it was
any other night than this one I could do
that but I don't plan on cutting it as
it turned out with all the applause that
went nine minutes Wow I think they were
very pleased the producers thought you
know that was worth going late for